oh
[Music]
now we've talked about jurassic park
several times before on the channel it's
one of the most important and impactful
vfx movies of all time it's also just
like an excellent film but a lot of
people still think that the effects from
that movie hold up today
because they do
so why is that in contrast in more
recent years the jurassic world movies
have come out and those movies have
incredible visual effects in them from a
technical standpoint they are absolutely
far superior to the original jurassic
park and yet audiences still feel
that they're not as good
i find this question fascinating and so
to answer that i think we need to study
the original film and their approach to
visual effects so jordan and i sat down
to watch one of the most classic scenes
from the movie when the t-rex breaks out
of the park
anytime you see a close-up of the
dinosaur it's real stan winston's team
made a full-scale animatronic t-rex and
that's what you're seeing every time
there's a close-up and it looks great
because it's real and how awesome is it
as an artist to have a perfect reference
on set in the same lighting conditions
in other footage that you can always
reference to see how closely
speaking right this is the first like
actual like cg shot we see of the t-rex
they're very particular about when and
how they're showing the dinosaur which
is honestly i think a large part as to
why it holds up spielberg understood
that the cgi here wasn't going to be
perfectly photoreal
it was the first time he'd ever worked
with cgi and so he approached it kind of
from the same sort of experience of
working with miniatures that because
that was his experience and so a lot of
those same sort of techniques
cross over so he decided to basically
obscure it the best way he could very
very intense directional lighting
shooting at night having rain on
everything so everything's reflective
yeah because it's very easy to have cgi
things be reflective remember this is
the first film that ilm is doing right
off doing t2 yeah and of course
terminator 2 they decided to do as a
chrome guy because again chrome
reflections are easier to do
than actually trying to figure out how
much reflected light would would tint
the color of a thing
here he steps down and puddles splash up
which is interesting because there's no
actual puddles under the feet yeah he's
just stepping on mud but it's like he's
stepping on like an actual puddle and
it's another thing that again it doesn't
necessarily make sense but it cements it
even further the shadow matching is
so good yeah like very very very very
similar especially considering that the
shadow that they had is just a simple
planar shadow and that's it this was
before ambient occlusion was a thing so
it's like technically the ground should
be a little bit darker
directly underneath his belly there
versus out underneath his head but with
a single shadow plane there on the
bottom you're kind of missing out on
that and you can you can see it you can
you can really see it here especially
like right next to his feet here yeah
it's just the same blank darkness going
out from that shadow
then we immediately cut to inside of the
car looking at the t-rex this one kind
of betrays itself a little bit because
we are looking at a very strong
headlight coming from the perspective of
the camera yep so that's immediately
going to give it a little bit of a
different feel as opposed to every other
shot where it's more edge lit kind of
from behind into the side here you're
kind of exposing a little bit of the
dated nature of the visual effects when
it's in bright headlights versus one
screen top light and the lightning
strikes which helps obviously cement the
composite
the car here is completely practical
they knocked a real car over you can see
it right here you see the cables
on the little tables that are supposed
to like hold it together yeah and the in
the action of the moment you can't quite
tell what they are but it's totally what
they are and then yeah he bites the tire
bites off the transmission or whatever
when i first saw this i was like oh wow
okay so they had the the car flipped
over they must have crushed it somehow
and they just like kind of married the
animation of the t-rex to it and just
added fake tires because the tires
looked weird just before filming this
discovered that the entire car here is
computer generated insane which
i don't think anyone ever noticed yeah
it's so no one ever noticed they're like
oh yeah it's just a car
[Music]
of course it goes without saying
animation sells this and the method they
actually use to animate the trx is
actually pretty interesting so we
recently had adam savage on the react
couch with us and he broke down exactly
what they did the dinosaur input device
is an absolutely important piece of
special effects history this was what
allowed physical animators who worked
with stop motion to actually use a set
of potentiometers built into a framework
that looked like a dinosaur to animate
the dinosaurs for jurassic park dude so
rather than cg people moving sliders it
was stop mow animators literally moving
things in in a sense it's like
stop-motion mocap yes it's stop-motion
mocap and later on pixar used that same
philosophy to build animation software
that you didn't have to be a cg animator
to use oh yeah by the way subscribe adam
savage on the react couch coming soon
the challenges they faced back then are
easy today like the limitations of their
render engines and textures and lighting
and stuff the challenges we face today
came second nature to these artists
because they were top tier artists and
so being able to replicate what they put
into making these shots work comes down
more to the filmmaking and experience
than it does the fancy rendering engines
so
what i think we should do
is try to take some of our modern
approaches that they struggled with back
then the rendering engines the
compositing all of that is relatively
easy for us today right but if we can
kind of just apply the same sort of
aesthetic and techniques that they used
back then
then maybe we can overcome the sort of
problems that jurassic world had so
hopefully we can make something that is
the best of both
world and park
and gain an even deeper appreciation for
the insane work that went into this and
just how groundbreaking it was
all right now it's time to actually do
it in a day
let's go and looking at this like this
whole backdrop here is just speaking
jurassic park to me this was its destiny
we gotta use it for that we just have to
do it at like a miniature scale and
pretend it's bigger so that's exactly
what we did we decided to do a full-on
miniature shoot of jurassic park in our
backyard so we got some 16th scale
miniature jeeps we wetted down all of
the mud and the leaves to make it all
reflective and that allowed us to go on
to focus on the lighting which i believe
to be probably the most critical
component to making the t-rex look
lifelike so we tried to approach our
lighting the same way the filmmakers did
on jurassic park we had a big spotlight
shooting down coming from behind and
above our whole scene we had a tiny bit
of fill so that the front wasn't
perfectly dark but i didn't think the
spotlight was quite enough to really
connect the t-rex to the scene because
we have all of the struggles of doing a
miniature set as well that we have to
overcome so i decided to add a little
light for a street lamp literally
putting a little light into the shot to
kind of bounce some more orangish light
to kind of get some color contrast in
there i think will help sell the overall
scale of the shot on top of that we are
going to add a huge amount of rain now
we got some of that in camera there on
set but the problem that i didn't really
anticipate water droplets at miniature
scale are the size of fists and it
instantly made those jeeps look like
toys so that meant that we had to keep
everything wet but dry off the cheeps i
i ended up being pretty pleased with the
sort of results we ended up getting it
almost feels like we could drop it into
the original movie because you know they
had giant aloe vera trees back then we
have our plates we'll combine those
later because right now i'm more
concerned about how are we going to get
a cg dinosaur
i found this beautiful free model online
that is totally unusable
so we got to do a little better normally
when we need a 3d model we hit all the
big ones turbo squid cg trader and then
you sort by price and you go to the free
ones what is freely available a lot of
the time the free stuff is pretty good
in this situation though uh
so i got to thinking
and i realized it's always been a dream
of mine to drop the big bucks on a 3d
model like that on turbo speed because
you see them they show up at the top
search results because turbosquid wants
you to buy the expensive models and i
was like someday someday i'll be able to
afford a 3d model well thanks to the
power of using other people's money
i test jordan with finding a 3d model of
a t-rex and he finds one that costs 254
dollars
i got bougie taste
this is the daddy this is the granddaddy
model
i think we should buy that super
expensive 3d model oh my god it feels so
this is a moment isn't it this is for
all of us you made it
yes yeah i feel like we finally made it
hey ren can we all press it together
you know what all right all right you
guys ready yep i'm excited
[Music]
card declined
[Laughter]
now that we have our t-rex we've got to
animate it now the problem is that we
don't have the same sort of dinosaur
input device that they had at ilm but
what we do have is a motion capture suit
and we also have access to the world's
most talented and impressive motion
capture performance artist
in the world all right i'm going to call
clown
what's up
[Laughter]
do you like animals
do you like extinct animals which
animals are extinct name an
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i was hoping that you would do us the
honor of being the mo-capped actor for a
tyrannosaurus rex
are you saying i have tiny arms
basically we're trying to recreate the
scene from the original jurassic park
movie with the same lighting and
conditions and rain and whatnot but we
don't have the animation shops to be
able to honor the ilm artists who made
the original t-rex if you can't do this
i totally understand we'll just call up
our b choice andy circus and we'll get
him on it um but i i mean if you don't
want him to be on this project
yeah
you don't need it cause i'm coming in
yeah
yes yes
it's the role you were born for man
cool i'll let you get back to the last
bite of your cake and i will
uh see you then bye clinton
i'll get our hands in there
[Music]
guys i'm here with a very special
announcement we have
some incredible new inventory available
right now on corridor digital dot store
the thing that i am most proud of is the
brand new bomber jacket okay this thing
has a beautiful map design on the inside
that our very own gabe peregrino came up
with and designed himself it's all the
locations we've filmed at in la over the
years it came out so good i'm so proud
of this thing but we were only able to
make a few hundred because that's the
way that it is right now and so if you
want this jacket you gotta get over
there right now record digital.store if
you order now it'll be available for you
before christmas so that's awesome and
we also have a huge slate of incredible
inventory available right now just in
time before christmas we have this sick
trucker hat we also have the mocap
trucker hat don't forget about that one
we've got this incredible new book bag
it's got sweet little tags on it we also
have women's cuts joggers jackets hats
you name it we got it but it sells out
fast check it out quarterdigital.store
if you're a member of our website don't
forget you get 15 off all merch all the
time and you get first dibs if you guys
aren't subscribed on the site this is
the best way to support us and if you
just want to rep us we try to make cool
stuff that we enjoy that we enjoy
wearing that feels nice looks nice and
is um affordable so thanks for the
support thanks for watching and um i'm
gonna
i'm gonna t-rex back on out of here back
to the video see you guys later
we have brought in clint today because
he is the best motion capture artist
alive today and now he's going to be
a tyrannous rex i'm glad clint came
through because i didn't want to have to
call my backup option andy circus
last time we hung out it didn't really
go too well but you know clint he came
through and he's our number one choice
one win for everyone right i hadn't had
a chance to look at any dinosaur
reference or
all i know is what i remember of
jurassic park and what's that one guy
jim carrey in that one movie where he
pretended to be a raptor
my recollection of dinosaurs is what i'm
bringing to the table
okay um we just get him kind of like
walking through maybe like a little bit
of like a sniff in the car and then
going
and then walking off that's like bare
minimum what we need to make this whole
project work
it's inspiring
all right oh my god
and that's a wrap on clint
i just
i just remembered what it was like to be
a dinosaur that's all i that's all i had
we now have everything we need we've got
the animation data we've got the cgt rex
and we've got the footage it is now time
to piece these things together
so before we ever had clint's master
performance i ran some initial tests
with the cheaper version of the dinosaur
essentially my approach was to take a
human form which is you know two legs
just like a dinosaur two arms just like
a dinosaur a head and an egg and just
kind of move them in space so that those
legs are longer uh the neck is longer
and just the proportions match that of a
t-rex and for the most part it worked
pretty well it looks a bit barney-like
it looks a little rubbery but overall it
kind of gets the job done mind you this
was with motion captured data that was
not emulating a dinosaur at all with
clint's performance i mean he was
beautifully emulating the spirit of the
t-rex so we were able to take that
stretch those hips stretch those legs
and shrink those little arms down and
shove that in a much higher end model
and rigging it i figured would be kind
of a similar exercise to this one but i
kind of came into some issues the
x-sense motion capture does a really
nice job of stabilizing the motion
capture meaning it's keeping the feet on
the ground the whole time
and it looks awesome for any human that
you're rigging it does a really nice job
i don't think it was made to turn human
into dino because once i elongated those
bones the little bit of noise that
existed in the human version was
extrapolated dramatically and all of a
sudden the little bit of shaking that
you got was way bigger for the feet and
they started clipping right through the
floor it was pretty egregious
and what i ended up having to do was
going almost frame by frame so that
anytime they click below i shift them
back up it was a lot of work but i think
i got it to a pretty good place
so much like the original artists of
jurassic park you have to do some manual
adjusting of the bones the performance
was kind of lackluster when ren first
reviewed it he was like it looks like
barney the dinosaur because it's it's
literally just a human being moving with
like this static head and very little
life so when clint bends over i shifted
all the spine bones to kind of counter
it as like a counterweight and then hand
animated the head looking up and the jaw
opening and roaring and doing all that
stuff to try and give it some additional
life
another big giveaway that this is mocap
data is that the tail obviously has no
reference of how to move or where to
move because clint as far as i know
doesn't have a tail what we did here is
we created what's called spline dynamics
where you basically take the first bone
in the chain and the last bone in the
chain and you attach them via a cord as
you can see this green little line it's
running from the base bone all the way
to the tip and that line the tension on
that line is literally what is driving
the dynamics of the spline so wherever
this one goes this one tries to hang on
via the chord it helps add a lot of
realism to the motion of the tail itself
because when the hips swing the tail has
a delayed swing those are just a couple
little things that we tried to do to add
some additional realism to our animation
of the dinosaur
so we've got our dyno rigged and walking
and roaring and looking good now we got
to get him into our scene and the
re-lighting aspect of this is always the
trickiest unless you come prepared and
luckily on the shoot day i was able to
take out my 360 camera and get a bunch
of different exposures of the actual
lighting environment itself when all
those are stitched together that's
called an hdri and what i'm able to do
with that is basically put it on a giant
sphere in the scene expand that sphere
and use the luminance of that hdri to
light the scene exactly as it was lit on
the day this shot for example we have
the hdri which is giving the ambient
light that's all the bounce light that's
coming from around it's giving you some
of the main lights too
but typically with hdris at least what i
found is they don't give you strong
enough main lights so i've supplemented
in some additional lights inside of
octane to really up the intensity of
that lighting and make it look a lot
better so you're getting a really nice
rim light when the dinosaur passes by
and you're getting a real nice natural
shadow being cast on the floor and on
the jeep scan that we got ren had a
really good idea to actually scan the
jeep models that we used in the
miniature shoot so that we could
position them in 3d space and use the
shadows from the dinosaur to cast over
the actual geometry of the jeep we can
then use those shadows in the
compositing stage and get a whole other
level of realism for the look all right
i mean that pretty much wraps up
everything that i'm doing so i'm going
to start kicking out some render passes
for ren so he can get started on the
compositing phase
okay so we've got the dinosaur render
ready to go as you can see i can scrub
through the whole thing here so this is
looking pretty good but before i can
actually mess with this any further i've
got to combine the plates of footage
that we shot outside so this is the
footage with all of the lights on
straight from the camera here and we
need to paint out the light that's easy
enough
gone so i'm able to actually bring back
in a lot of the rain elements that i
created by literally sprinkling some
water in the air and i got a little
street lamp that i added and i put it in
the same place as the light here so
we've got the street lamp and we've got
the atmospherics but
i couldn't get around the idea that it
just looked like a bunch of aloe vera
sitting there because it is so i ended
up just finding an image of a jungle on
the internet and i dropped it in now
obviously a green jungle photo like this
is not what we're after so tint it blue
get the levels correct and voila look at
that i think this ends up looking a
little better because of the depth that
it creates in the shot because now it
looks like the set actually extends into
a jungle and it helps alleviate the sort
of miniature look that we had going
we've got our shot and i think it looks
pretty decent it's time to drop in our
t-rex
so i've got the t-rex in the scene but
to really marry the render to the
footage we need shadows and
traditionally what you do for a shadow
pass is basically just drop in your
black and white render of a shadow you
know drop the opacity a little bit and
get your shadow that's what we usually
always do but here we're doing something
a little different notice how the
specular highlights that are showing up
through the shadow that's not how light
works these specular highlights are
coming from the lights if the t-rex was
actually blocking them those big
specular highlights wouldn't be there
but fortunately i've got the footage
without the lights on so i'm going to
actually use the black part of the
shadow as essentially a track mat to
reveal the plate without the lights on
so now it's only showing up wherever the
shadow is hitting the ground and the
jeep and that's really cool because it
still gives you that shadow look
but it's actually doing it in an
optically correct way you know you
wouldn't really see this method used
very often in modern movies because they
would just pretty much do the entire
muddy ground in cg because it's like not
that hard to do for vfx houses but since
we knew exactly where the effects were
going to be applied we knew how to
support it with the filmmaking so the
dyno is in there but it's still not a
done shot here we need more atmospherics
we need rain and thanks to action v
effects they have several packs of rain
just falling through the sky rain
hitting the ground and splashing back up
rain hitting windshields and sliding
down the glass
my roll of thumb when it comes to adding
elements like rain or fire or smoke or
dust or whatever is that more is usually
better with everything on
this is our final shot and i think it
looks pretty dang good i'm going to go
ahead and let this render overnight and
tomorrow morning jordan and i will take
a look
here we go we've got it now we've
finished the shot we have accomplished
what the jurassic park period of time
couldn't even do
that makes sense doesn't it that makes
so much sense but okay enough has been
said here's the shot
[Music]
i mean okay
we set out to do a few specific things
obviously we couldn't get the whole
production value of a jurassic world or
jurassic park movie that being said i
think we kind of nailed a couple of the
aspects very well one i think you're
rendering of the dyno
very good thank you very much the
spotlight is perfectly placed and i
think having that street lamp in there
as just an extra element is really
pulling it all together yeah and i gotta
say i'm actually surprised at how well
the mocap held up that was that was one
area i was really suspicious of and it's
not perfect i'm really happy with how
far we got in the time that we had
overall clinton did a great job but i
don't think this compares to the actual
animation from jurassic park i totally
agree with you 100
because there are only a few vfx shots
in the original jurassic park they were
able to put the tender love and care
into each and every single animation and
it also helps that they were absolutely
geniuses
that's very helpful for one thing it's
hard to kind of get this sort of like
mass
clint doesn't have a giant tail that
weighs a quarter of his body either you
know a t-rex literally has a head this
way and a tail that way with the feet in
the middle
and that kind of acts as like a
counterbalance to his entire body and
when you don't have that
next time next time we have clint be a
dinosaur we're going to give him a big
tail yeah i could just hang on his back
too yeah i'm okay with that it doesn't
feel like a person in a suit to me at
this stage which i think is a win
already yeah and that's what i'm most
proud about is that like yeah there's
some rough surfaces to this but like
it's it it works you know it it shows
that less is more this shot if this was
a modern movie
it'd be all cg brush behind the
dinosaurs and probably have a the whole
ground be replaced all of the rain the
whole shot cg might as well be right
that's how they would do it these i
would think so and most of this shot is
real whether or not it's what we filmed
in the backyard or the actual real rain
place we got from action vfx the only
thing that's fake is the dinosaur you
know like i think this is a pretty dang
good render i think it's worth a high
five dude i'll take it
vfx is about so much more than what you
can just render out of a computer it
takes a lot of you know artistic intent
and insight around the whole process to
achieve something that not only looks
real but makes you believe that it's
real even if you think our shot isn't
that good we were not trying to actually
make a better vfx shot or do something
in less time the goal here was to simply
celebrate the amount of artistic skill
that went into making the jurassic park
movie
so much more went into those sequences
than just hitting some buttons on a
computer so it's not hard to imagine why
jurassic world doesn't work as well
because certain aspects of that film
just aren't as masterful as jurassic
park in jurassic park there were 63
visual effects shots but in jurassic
world there were over 2 000 of them and
at that scale the craftsmanship gets a
little diluted they did not use their
effect sparingly and i think dr malcolm
said it best you stood on the shoulders
of geniuses to accomplish something as
fast as you could you didn't earn the
knowledge for yourselves so it didn't
require any discipline to attain it your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should
oh man thank you so much for watching
this was so much fun to do leave a
comment down below with what other sort
of historical vfx you want us to sort of
reapproach and explain why they're so
special and also subscribe because we
got some really fun content coming your
way